well thank you sam it's a great pleasure
to be here at yale
and and to be with all of you fellow
teachers and we're all in this kind of
the same thing together
um and yeah i mean the connection with
india
sam mentioned this or i mentioned that
sam says i might remind all of you if
you don't happen to know
yale university was established by elihu
yale who was the governor of madras
india in the early 1600s
around 1638 something like that he
establishes
yale universe named it after himself uh
shamelessly uh after having
spent a career of kind of milking the
profits out of
india from east india company to kind of
a tone for that i think he
established a university so there's a
connection
with yale and india that goes back
several centuries
and that itself is fascinating
um the but the the story of islam
in india which is what uh
my particular interest is as sam
mentioned i i live two years in the
peace corps in iran
and uh i made a a a
very important lucky trip to india while
i was in iran
i had already learned persian and so i
was already kind of and i
already spent a year living in tabriz
iran and i became kind of
sensitized to islamic culture persian
culture
and i go to india and i thought india
was all hindu
that's all that was my sense i just all
the textbooks kind of said that's what i
i didn't expect to find uh such a
profound
influence of both iranian and islamic
influence
in south asia and in a sense
my whole career has been trying to kind
of work that out
you know how did islam become so deeply
invested in and sink such deep roots
in this very different culture this
hindu buddhist
culture this is back in the 60s when i
made that trip 63 to be exact
and i look around and i see this
architecture
this clearly looks like isfahan you know
anyone who goes to the taj mahal
bang and you realize these were persian
architects
you look at the script of urdu it's
persian script
you listen to music yeah you look at the
clothing you look at
you begin to learn vocabulary it's all
persian not all of it but a lot of it
and so this whole connection between
iran and india
these two powerful civilizations and
the religious component islam and the
hindu buddhist
giant traditions of south asia and how
they interact has been a
fascinating question that i'm still kind
of trying to sort out
um just to kind of heads up a couple of
major books that i
want to i wrote them on the board i
don't have any handout i apologize for
that
but here are some books i think that are
really leading books give a general
survey of
islam in south asia francis robinson
an englishman has got a number of books
his book islam and muslim history in
south asia is a
is a classic oxford 2000.
carl ernst
writes a lot on sufism and i know you've
been reading and hearing a lot about
that
major story here uh a book entitled
eternal garden
uh mysticism history and politics at a
south asian sufi center
it's a it's a very important and very
accessible study uh
all these are i hope i edited a book
called
india's islamic traditions came out in
2000
and that's a series of essays written by
scholars coming from different
perspectives
who are collectively uh trying to
understand you know
what what kinds of traditions literary
artistic
uh historical legal uh there's a whole
range of of
things that that one can talk about
and uh that is historically oriented
from 7
11 to 1750
and then finally anna marie schimel uh
islam
in the indian subcontinent she the
german scholar
uh one of the uh leading scholars of
of south asian islam um and that
again a very accessible book there so
what i'm going to do is kind of give up
hopefully about a 45-minute overall
presentation here
but uh i invite questions
if they are of you know to clarify a
point that may not be clear but don't
don't be bashful
about asking and then afterwards i will
have about 20 minutes or so
15 20 minutes of general questioning to
kind of
move into more a more substantive nature
now where to begin well i always begin
with a map
and this map is loaded with important
information because it what it does
it's based on the 1931 census now the
1931
census was the last really good census
the british did in india
you know they started these decennial
censuses in the in the 1800s i think 18
uh 71 was the first they did and every
10 years they
they did the census of india to find out
who who was here
and uh this and the 31 was the last
really good one 1941 of course
england was otherwise preoccupied to put
it mildly
uh and so we don't really have a they
weren't
because they were fighting the war uh
that's not really all that good a a
census
and then of course after that's you have
independent south asia in 1951 you have
india and pakistan
but you could already see the map of
pakistan and bangladesh
kind of
present even before the two states
emerge
because you have a predominant muslim
population in eastern bengal but not
western bengal
western punjab but not eastern punjab
and where's my pointer here's what i
gotta yeah this is great
i think this is it here in the india
yeah there you go
this is all the punjab west punjab is
predominantly muslim you get up to
what 75 percent 50 60 70 80
muslims in the western majora but not
the east and
conversely in in bengal
the eastern portion is mainly muslim but
not the western
very few muslims in the heart of the
highlands of central india
but then the deccan you get in the south
you get some more
so one of the questions that's always
kind of animated my own
research is how do you explain this
uneven distribution of muslims in south
asia
especially given the fact that south
asia is home to one-third
of the world's muslim population that's
more
more muslims are in south asia than
there are in the middle east
that's a shocking not but not by much
it's a
it's a close race but
it's amazing to think about that you
know after indonesia which is the
world's largest muslim population
uh the next two india uh next three
india pakistan bangladesh and they're
all very close
very similar population somewhere around
three or four hundred million
each one of them you add those together
and you begin to realize that south asia
in terms of demography really is the
center of gravity of the muslim world
this is a jarring fact because we've
always been taught to believe that
you know the middle east is somehow the
the heartland of islam historically of
course that's obviously true
but the area where it sunk its roots
demographically in terms of
muslim population it really is south
asia
and so this is the and then then you
look at the map and you ask
why is it that the western the
northwestern
and the far eastern bengal and some
extent the deccan
how is it that those areas became most
receptive
to islam i'm going to try to present
some
some answers to that this morning
as well as some remarks about the nature
of islamic
piety and how it differs or compares
with islam elsewhere in the muslim world
and again feel free to raise any
questions
as we move along historically
we go back to the 7th century i know
that dick bullet
has already uh talked about the umayyad
and the
abbasid periods so suffice it to say
that this is the period that where islam
first
encounters western india sinned in
particular the province of sin where the
indus
river empties into the arabian sea
and it happens in actually in 7-eleven
is when muhammad bin qasam
uh who is a general under the
umayyad caliph conquers
the lower indus area which is now
karachi area in southern pakistan
and that's a very important moment in
terms of the interaction with islam in
south asia
this is the arab dial these are the
vehicles that
were and they have by the way these
haven't changed in about a thousand
years
i actually sailed on one of these across
the arabian sea
they still make these things in india as
well as east africa
these were the vessels that have
traditionally been used connecting
the middle east at least the maritime
connection between the middle east and
south asia
and you can't really understand the
settlement of muslims in
along the western coast of india without
understanding the trade routes
which undergird the contact between
the the the persian gulf area and in
india
okay so here is a map showing you what
basically happens
as i said in the year 711 sinned is
conquered by this
by a muslim general who establishes
their area
very briefly several important legacies
i want to just
briefly mention juridically in terms of
law
very significantly muhammad bin qasim
the
the conqueror of of sindh
ruled that hindus and
buddhists will be treated as zimmi's
which is to say
people of the book now that might be
jarring itself
because we think you know islam
understands itself
as you know a religion of the book the
book being
obviously the the torah and the gospels
as well as the quran
the quran is simply a restatement of
these earlier attempts to get god's
message through the people
so it's easy to imagine how jews and
christians are already included in this
larger category of people of book but
what do we say about hindus and
buddhists
the ruling that indians would be
juridically defined as people of the
book
means that already there is a stretching
of the idea of book
which is to say administrators governors
the very first governor
muslim governor arab governor in india
was was accommodating himself to the
reality
that uh that we i mean we're a thin
ruling class
we need to uh
we need to accommodate ourselves to the
fact that the
to rule these people we need to include
them in this larger
category which had already been uh
worked out by uh
jurists and uh with a tradition of a
liberal
juridical understanding of india from
the very beginning
also brahmanas the priests of india were
kind of reconfirmed as the elite
community
by muhammad bin qasim and uh
so there was no effort in other words to
upset or transform the social order
rather the first muslims in india uh
were there they understood their mission
as being to kind of confirm the existing
social order which is to say to confirm
the caste
system
all this is important because subsequent
regimes muslim regimes in india
look back to this first founding
encounter
as a precedent for how in the real world
uh indians can be governed uh because
obviously muslims were
as a ruling class a very thin tiny
minority among a vast sea of non-muslims
um and there's a brief comment about
agriculture
which is always fascinating to me to
think that you know
we always hear about the the so-called
colombian exchange of of uh
plants and animals across the atlantic
ocean since columbus crossed it
but there was an earlier agricultural
exchange across the indian ocean
when the arabs conquered india they
brought back with them
a whole range of crops which totally
transformed
the the uh agricultural landscape of the
middle east
uh cotton lemon lime orange sugar
uh all of these of course are are either
arabic or sanskrit and
the words come from that they tell us
their own story but much more
for certain strands of wheat and rice
were transplanted in the middle east
from monsoon asia
so the the diet of the roman world
and the byzantine world more precisely
was radically transformed
as a result of this encounter with with
india
the abbasid period sees a kind of a
withdrawal
uh beyond the indus river uh
from 1750 to 1250 uh uh
eight um
the real encounter with islam in india
happens not by arabs but by
turkic groups who had been migrating
from east asia into the west along the
silk road connecting china
with the eastern mediterranean
and the area that is particular interest
is this area of horizon in central asia
right up here in the
um where i put the circle bohara
these areas in the oaks river region
this area
in the 10th and 11th centuries
was undergoing a dramatic um
cultural renaissance in the sense that
you had the
iranian peoples conquered by the arabs
in the mid 7th century
and about 300 years later that submerged
iranian culture kind of bubbles up to
the surface
and when it reappears it reappears
uh in a form that has assimilated
itself with uh with uh with arab culture
sort of the arabic script now replaces
the old persian script
many arabic words loanwords are
assimilated into the persian
language in fact modern persian
derives from this moment
it's also this place in this time that
political ideas the status of the sultan
as a non-religious leader
emerges in this persian renaissance
period
of the 10th and 11th and 12th centuries
in horison this area that i'm
circled the kf
of islam is becoming progressively
weaker
in the in the 10th 11th and 12th
centuries and as that happens
the sultan uh kind of replaces the
caliph at least as a
as a political uh leader and
this is important because the idea of
the sultan
acquires a certain notion of of someone
who is above religion
he's a ruler of all peoples because
horus-san this area was not just muslim
it was of course there were shees there
were sunnis but there are also buddhists
there
a large jewish population very large
christian population and historian
christians were there shaman turkish
population in other words you had a
variety of different peoples in khorasan
in the 9th 10th and 11th century uh kind
of
cooking up this this idea of a of a
secular
islamic regime where religion and state
are
have a de facto separation
um and of course persian languages as i
said invented at this time
it's always struck me it's fascinating
that you know we always talk about how
english language
emerged about 300 years after
the norman conquest of 1066 you get 300
years later you get chaucer
another couple hundred years you get
shakespeare uh
where english and french have kind of
merged
after 300 years after that conquest same
thing happens with persian
about 300 years after the arab conquest
of iran
uh this synthesis of arabic and persian
takes place
and it happens in this area
then turks begin to move into north
india and they carry this
hybridized culture with them
in the 10 30 is the the
is the date of the mahmoud of ghazni a
turkish
general who makes these raids and these
arrows are indicating
raids of india he's sacking temples
in order to acquire wealth to mobilize
uh to create a larger sultanate
to the west because this the horizon
this area to the west was what was
kind of the prize india was only used as
kind of a source of wealth
uh in the in the 11th century
it's not till the 12th and 13th century
that we begin to get settlement of
of turks moving down these migration
corridors and that's the term i would
use
to describe uh these
these these roots oops sorry let me go
back
ah what am i doing go back here
yeah the term i would use is a migration
corridor these are actually
uh roots old trade routes
bringing horses and silver into india
india has always been deficient in two
things
uh horses don't do well in india
because it is a competition for land uh
by peasant population
uh plus the there's no grassland uh that
as you have in central asia
so there's a constant need to to import
war horses by
all dynasties of india and secondly
there's no silver mines in india
so india's has an old history of
exporting textiles
importing uh silver and war horses
and so these roads that connect
samarkand and bohara and central asia
with south asia
are basically trade routes moving down
into lahore
from lahore to delhi and from delhi east
down the gangetic plain toward bengal as
well as south
into gujarat and from there into the
declan plateau
and these migration corridors while
they're commercial
they are also um let me go back to that
oh yeah
they are also important because they
they facilitate the migration of of
large populations who are being moved
out of central asia because of the
mongols
and when this happens uh now we get
a true um turco or turkish
kind of muslim population migrating into
into india
delhi becomes filled up with populations
of transplanted immigrants
who are fleeing the terror of the mongol
invasions of of central asia
and when they come they arrive with
a sense of authority that's already been
kind of worked out in that persian
uh renaissance this
very crude kind of mapping is what you
see on coins
that were minted in this period where
you have a statement of the credo of
islam there is no god but
but allah and muhammad is his prophet uh
and then the name of the caleb will be
on one side of the coin
the sultan will be on the other side of
the coin and the son of the sultan is
often times as well on that coin
so you have this kind of downward flow
of authority uh
that has become already established in
the way coinage was
was made by the 13th century
but when the first turks actually
conquer north india
i'm going to show some coins here to
illustrate again this theme of
accommodation
i mentioned already how muhammad bin
gasem
ruled that hindus and buddhists of sindh
were people of the book that's basically
coming reckoning with the reality uh
that
we we need to accommodate ourselves to
this
this large non-muslim population so what
do we do we call them people the book
when the first turkish conquerors take
north india
they basically take over the existing
format
of coinage so here are indian coins that
go back to the
mid 1700s under the hindu shahi dynasty
where you have on one side a horseman on
the left
with a spear in his hand and on the
other side of the coin you have a bull
so you have this bull and horseman
established
a formula of coinage by hindu dynasties
that had been already been around
for for hundreds of years before the
turks arrived
the first coins of muhammad of gore
who's the first ruler of
india follows exactly the same format
you'll notice there's no arabic
no persian what you have is a
a a horseman on the left and a bull on
the right
uh extraordinary example of how
the the turkish rulers are of necessity
having to accommodate themselves to the
existing
reality that bankers money lenders will
only accept coins which they recognize
if you throw up a coin at them with with
arabic on it which nobody can read
anyway
at this early stage it's not going to be
accepted
so what you do is you mint coins which
will be accepted
the point i'm trying to make is that
muslim rulers again
were having to adjust themselves to this
reality
uh here is another coin a rajput coin
the chohana rajputs were the last great
indian dynasty of north india
before turks conquered them and their
coins
had on one side this image of the
goddess lakshmi
a famous goddess of wealth uh and and
you see her there
uh uh the kind of indian beauty of the
of the 12th century on the left and on
the right
you have the name of the the chohana
rajputs in devanagari script
the indian script and then what happens
when muhammad al-gore shows up
behold all you've heard about you know
muslims not having images on their on
their coins
forget that this is reality
we are accommodating to the reality we
need to have coins which the indian
bankers will accept
we need to have coins that are already
familiar otherwise
uh what are we doing here so muhammad
agora starts minting coins with lakshmi
on one side
and with his name in sanskrit dave
inaugury script on the opposite side
pragmatism is overcoming ideology quite
obviously
uh and yet look at this double game that
muhammad agor
the first turkish ruler of north india
is playing
he's ruling both afghanistan and north
india
the coins that are mended for
circulation at afghanistan
follow the traditional classic arabic
formula
and you'll find this this would have
circulated anywhere in the muslim world
and it has all the formula i talked
about earlier where you have god
caliph sultan son of sultan downward
authority
all in arabic there's no imagery no
images nothing like that at all
but the same sultan at the same time is
minting these coins
in india so i i think this is a
fascinating point uh illustrating this
whole idea of of the
need to accommodate uh politically with
this reality
the turks were uh ruling this area in
north india in the
in the uh 13th century this is more or
less the extent of their rule
but you can see they swept very quickly
down the gangetic plain
uh knocking over these these rajput
houses
the chandelas the paramaras and so forth
in in central and northern india
and then they establish the delhi
sultanate the delhi sultanate
was the first ruling house
of north india and you can see in these
this map
uh the territorial extent under the
founder
muhammad of ghor and his slave successor
ibec
uh his name is up there at the very top
rules this very this this heartland of
upper india
and then his successor il another turk
another turkish slave actually
uh is is takes this much larger area so
this
north india becomes the the heartland of
uh muslim rule
uh in by the 13th century when the delhi
sultana is established
architecturally we begin to see uh
spectacular monuments this is a minaret
it's often been thought of as kind of a
victory tower because obviously
if a mozin is doing his call to the
prayer at the top of this thing nobody's
going to hear him
this is before microphones
uh and loudspeakers uh
and so it's oftentimes thought this is
really a
art historians dispute exactly what this
tower was all about it's clearly a
statement though of occupation
nothing like this had existed in india
prior to the to the turkish arrival this
is the very first
architectural muslim indo-muslim
monument
in india the the great kutub binar it's
still the tallest minaret i believe in
the world
uh extraordinary monument in in is part
of this mosque
complex here's a close-up of it uh you
can see
uh juxtaposing uh white marble with red
sandstone
uh and and the writing on it is
not only arabic but also devanagari
uh indian workmen made this
they used local workmen and we actually
find on this tower
invocations not to allah and not only to
allah
but also to the the patron god
of uh craftsmen among the hindus
so it's a remarkable kind of monument
it's not just to islam
but also uh to the to to the workmen who
were who were building it
it was made of recycled columns
from either jain or hindu temples
stacked
end on end to give them greater height
you can see there's one
column here and then a second one is
stacked above it so you have these large
very high um enclosures
for prayer halls uh in this mosque
and uh but behind all this
is the larger story that i want to just
just briefly touch on
is the mongols were really the force
that were pushing
all this process in india the mongols of
course have swept across from china
in the 13th century of course they
succeed in conquering china
they never conquer india they can't get
beyond
the the hindu kush uh area
and that's important genghis khan
himself uh was knocking at the door of
india
in 12 21 or 1231 when he was there
uh but didn't make it through the fact
that the mongols were unable to conquer
india
meant that india became understood by
all these migrants who
were pushed out of central asia fleeing
the mongol terror
they began to see india as the true
heartland of islam especially
after the mongols proceeded to demolish
baghdad
and overthrow the caliph indeed abolish
the caliphate
so with and of course that was would be
tantamount to having rome
uh totally destroyed by the vandals
which of course partially did happen
uh but and and christianity thereby
understood as uh literally wiped off the
map
so for these people who are fleeing the
mongols
india became a refuge zone uh
for them pagan did not really mean hindu
it meant
mongol and all the rhetoric
in early indo-muslim literature
of the 13th to 14th century really is
inspired by that fact that it's the
mongols who are the true
uh uh who who are the pagans who are the
infidels
the kafirs so india then becomes an area
as i said earlier of of filling up
through these
following these migration corridors of
large numbers of people
fleeing the north india and the delhi
sultanate
becomes at least in north india well
established by the 13th and 14th century
last all the way down to the mid
to the early 16th century the deccan
in the south is never conquered it's
conquered but they can't hold it
so this is this long divide between
north india and the deccan
uh that uh that exists but behind all
that
uh underlined and red are the mongols
who as i said earlier do not succeed in
conquering india
but they they have driven all this this
persianized turkish population into
south asia
who now begin to see india as the the
true home of islam
given the fact that baghdad has been
destroyed in 1258
the caliph has been executed the office
has been abolished
and so the sultan of india becomes the
focus of many pious muslims who are now
looking for spiritual direction even
though the sultan
doesn't have a spiritual bone in his
body uh most of these guys are
are turkish slaves who have no
genealogical
connection with with aristocracy
whatever uh yet they're built up
by their ideologues by their their their
uh
uh their propagandists as these these
this focus of muslims
um as i said briefly south india was
conquered at least down
pretty far south uh two capitals were
established in the
in the 14th century in delhi and also in
dolatabad
here's delhi uh this is a 13th century
delhi
which still still looks like this today
these are the ramparts of
of what they called uh and delhi now
becomes identified
as the capital of india
from this point on any dynasty that has
pretensions of ruling india
has to control delhi
this is true all the way down to the
20th century when the british
need to establish themselves as the
natural rulers of india
they moved their capital in 1911 from
calcutta
to new delhi they did the same thing
that muslim dynasties had been doing for
the previous millennium
building another city of delhi not
occupying the same palaces
that the predecessors had done but alice
is nearby
or building new palaces uh so there's
another delhi in in the region
that's and in the south in the deccan
dholadabad was this co-capital
that the the sultans built and ruled
from there as well
uh here is the the great mosque in
dullarbad
the same idea stacking uh hindu temples
and on end hindu columns i should say
and
on end to give greater height to the
prayer hall here you see
exactly what i just described uh in in
the south
but there's a there's a memory of the
north india uh
here we have the corner of the dalatabad
mosque
in in the south and it it is kind of a
visual reminder of the kotovinar
in delhi so these migrants they've
already migrated from central asia to
north india
now they're migrating from north india
to the south but they're carrying with
them
this reminder of north india that the
the kotov
nara has kind of become the icon of
hindu
in of indo-muslim presence
and we see that echoed in this corner
engaged corner
tower in in the dalatabad mosque
so here's our here's our migration
corridor that i mentioned earlier
following those ancient trade routes
horse
trade routes from central asia into
south asia
moving on down to bijapur we see
monuments that are built
carrying with them a central asian
visual aesthetic you see you see domes
you see minarets you see arches pointed
arches
these become the elements kind of the
architectural vocabulary
of of mosque building in the 16th
century
uh when this deccan sultan down there is
established
and then from bijapur if we look at
kerala
which is off the roots now we're talking
about
coastal malabar coast this was not
settled by
migrants coming from the north uh along
those migration corridors
kerala muslims are muslims who would
sail the cross on those arab dials
and they have a very different
sensibility their their connection is
not with north india it's not with
turkish or persian culture they don't
speak or do
or or any of the north indian languages
they speak malayalam
which is the native language of of the
malar coast
and what's striking is when we look at
their architecture
you do not find arches pointed arches
you do not find domes uh or minarets
of the kind of standard vocabulary of
north india
but rather you find these wooden roof uh
kind of layers like a wedding cake which
in fact
imitates the same vocabulary of hindu
temples
so you notice here what's happening
another theme of accommodation once you
move
off that corridor that migration
corridor
and look at kerala you see that islam
has
accommodated itself visually and
architecturally with the local culture
that's a very important theme
because we begin to understand now that
islam is extremely flexible
in terms of how it accommodates itself
to indigenous cultures in south asia
and this is something you can oh
question please just if we could get the
name
of the previous the previous slide yeah
this
is the the mishka mosque built in 1510
it's been rebuilt uh many uh uh
but this is a basic design of it and
calicut
now calicut is a city on the coast the
malabar coast
this is where vasco da gama arrives when
europeans first connect europe
through maritime routes in 1498
is when vasco de gama succeeds in doing
what christopher columbus
failed to do which is to reach india
six years later he does it of course and
calacut is a
major center of the pepper trade and
this was where
and cardamom and all these spices of
south india
were flowing out into the indian ocean
world through the port of calicut
uh it was major metropolis and
this is the great mosque of calicut and
as i said
this is their the the the architecture
basically is
using the same vocabulary that was
already familiar to the people of kerala
uh if we talk about never mind carol
let's go to bengal bengal is also an
area that's very
far from these roots uh this migration
corridor
uh now we're for the the very end of
this
this endogangetic plane in far eastern
india
and what we find here is mosques
appearing
uh with distinctive characteristics you
have terra cotta
uh panels on on the on the walls
you have a a curved cornice uh
which is the classic design
of the uh the bengali
village hut our word bungalow
is derived from the word bengal which is
the bengal
style which is a curve made of thatched
and and bamboo uh it's it's curved so
that rain the monsoon rain which is very
high in bengal
uh will will will drain off so this idea
of a curved cornice is a very bengali
phenomenon
uh as well as the the terracotta panels
on the front it's all brick there's no
marble
or granite or hard stone in bengal you
build everything a brick
and what's extraordinary about this
monument is if we compare it with
temples of bengal lo and behold we find
the same architectural vocabulary we
have terra cotta
uh panels on the front we have the
curved cornice
which is derived again from this kind of
vernacular vocabulary of
village bengal and uh
so that in in bengal as in kerala
what we see is that that the form in
which the mosque
appears is thoroughly invested in
local culture the bengalis have borrowed
from the
bengali vocabulary bengali muslims are
using the same vocabulary in eastern
india
and again in kerala the same kind of
thing operates for there i could
make the same statement about the tamil
area in in the southeast coast
uh in orissa uh the point is that
when we move away from this kind of
central this migration corridor going
down the spine
of south asia then we see much more
combination to
indigenous culture
tamerlane invades india
in 13 um
98-99 he dies in 1405.
he does not stay to rule uh india
but his base is at summercon the
timor is but he shakes up north india in
the sense that
he destroys delhi delhi had been the
capital of
of of north india the successive
dynasties in the delhi sultanate for
for several centuries and now what
happens after after tamerlane
is that north india becomes um it loses
its focus
delhi is no longer the the center of uh
of uh indian indo-muslim polity and he
brings with them
a central asian sensibility here we have
the the tomb of of of of timor himself
in semicond
uh you see all these very extraordinary
elements
high drums uh vaulting techniques that
allow you to just soar up to the sky
this is all nude
ideas uh glazed tile covered all over
the surfaces of central asian
uh mosques uh and they're freestanding
and the overall effect then
is to is to is to be able to be seen
from afar i mean timor himself
uh introduces into islamic architecture
uh this idea of uh kind of over-the-top
uh extravagant uh visual statements
that you see and all of this is carried
into india
uh by the next great conqueror of north
india
these this this kind of glazed tile
techniques which of course is babur
b-a-b-u-r
babur uh and you can see from this
painting
this is not babur but this is this faint
of the family in the early 16th century
it's very central asian you can just see
from the facial characteristics that
these are not indians
these are people who have already who
have come from central asia
but a very cosmopolitan central asian
style is brought to north india
by babur who's depicted here
founding a garden uh it says in persian
that he's establishing uh he's planting
he's directing the planting of
pomegranates uh
in in his garden so we begin to get now
uh with 1526 babur
sweeps away the last dynasty of delhi
sultans in north india
and establishes the mogul empire which
is the largest
muslim empire in the world larger even
than the ottomans
or the safavids in in the middle east
although the three were roughly
contemporary uh and i'm sure you've
already been hearing a lot and reading a
lot about
the safavids and the ottomans so babur
brings to south asia
a similar central asian
aesthetic a similar central asian
sensibility
idea of politics idea of power is all
established during his reign 1526-1605
you can see how the moguls are repeating
what the dallas sultans had done several
centuries
earlier take over the central heartland
of north india
and then move out and conquer gujarat in
the west
bengal in the east and
what's extraordinary about the moguls is
that not babur but his grandson
akbar
in order to rule north india he departs
from the policy of
of earlier uh rulers which was to always
keep the rajputs at arm's length try to
conquer the rajputs the rajputs
were the the hindu ruling class
of north india before the the turks
arrived
what akbar does is he engages with the
rajputs
he brings them into the ruling class and
he
marries rajput princesses
which is very important because it means
that biologically each successive
generation of the mogul ruling house is
less and less turkic
and more and more indian you look at the
facial characteristics of the rajputs
now here we have jahangir who is the son
of
of akbar
akbar was it was a of pure turco persian
blood
but akbar's wife was a pure rajput
princess who's brought into the mughal
harem
and so that means that jahan gear
is biologically half rajput
jahangir in turn marries other rajput
women
princesses of course these are all
political marriages much like
europe knew roughly the same time uh
i mean that's how you cement uh
political relationships you you you
marry into the same families it's
exactly what's happening now with the
moguls
and i i would argue that this is
extremely significant because it means
that
that just as jahangir was one half
rajput
his son shah jahan builder of the taj
mahal
his old is is three quarters rajput
because
jahangir has also married a rajput woman
so that the element of turkic
biological content of the ruling mogul
house is becoming progressively less
turkic
and more rajput more indian
they don't even use turkish language
anymore they've forgotten that
persian is still patronized as the
language of of
rulership but in at home
they're speaking uh what we would now
recognize as hindi
or hindi urdu that's the space same
thing
different script but the point is that
the what was known as hindavi
or the local indian language was now
assimilated into the court
so did the mughals we can call them
muslim
but really they are becoming north
indian
they it's another example of
accommodation to
north indian culture and
his son jahangir's son shah jahan
builds of course the most spectacular
monuments that are familiar to
to many of us any visitor to india i
mean this is the
most extraordinary building in new delhi
in old delhi i should say shah jahanabad
means the city of shah jahan king of the
world
um and this is of course the building
from which jawaharlal
uh read off the the declaration of
of independence for india in august of
1947
standing up there in the top so this has
become again the symbol of
indian rulership i mean delhi had always
as i mentioned earlier been the
the center of muslim power
um in india and uh and now
it's interesting even though the british
had already built new delhi
only five miles away from this monument
nehru is announcing the the proclamation
of independent india from this monument
meaning he's identifying himself not
with the british but with the bogels
who had already become indian uh where
the british never did of course
in ways the british couldn't do so
shah jahan then is the patron of these
monuments which we all identify uh as
kind of the classic statement of
of of india itself the icon of india
as i mentioned earlier uh a perfect
transplant of iranian architecture
again delhi is on that and this is agra
of course just
100 miles southeast of delhi but it's on
that corridor
that that corridor of of persian
architecture that migration corridor
from central asia
uh into the heart of india so we hear we
see here an exact replica of the finest
persian aesthetic reflected in the taj
mahal
but not just the taj mahal but other
great monuments
of the north the great mosque in lahore
again sandstone and white marble red
sandstone
uh in in the south of the deccan we get
uh t murad or central asian uh motifs
again the glazed tile
you see here the glazed tile uh the the
the fall
the minarets are really this could
appear anywhere in central asia
again these are essentially transplants
from central asia into india
unlike those bengali or kerala mosque
that i showed earlier
sufism i know you've read a lot about
that
because this goes back to the question
of how islam accommodates itself to
india
the quran here's a central paradox
the quran unit uno was written in arabic
in fact there's a famous ayah in in
or statement in the quran where allah
says
we have created a arabic quran so that
you might understand
the assumption behind that statement is
that the koran
is addressing an arabic speaking
population
and of course for centuries and
centuries there was a kind of a
prohibition
against translating the koran out of
arabic into any other language
so the question becomes and we go back
to the central paradox
how does india where arabic is not
spoken
how does the quran communicate how is
the quran mediated
to a non-arabic speaking population
and i want to close with this these few
comments here about
how that paradox is overcome because it
really goes to the heart i think of
understanding islam in
in south asia how does islam
why is it that south asia is the is the
demographic heartland of the islamic
religion
not middle east but south asia when this
is a non-arabic speaking area
that's the central paradox one of the
answers
is that whereas the bible of course is
freely translated out of hebrew
and greek into latin into all the
vernacular languages with the
reformation
this does not happen with koran
so we need to redefine our understanding
of translation
we do not find a word by where
translation is not just
a word by word uh
translation of meaning from arabic into
other languages
rather the word translation needs to be
understood in a much broader kind of
metaphorical sense you have commentaries
of the quran which are written in
vernacular languages
you have histories of the prophet
muhammad and the other prophets of the
quran written in vernacular languages
and it's these bengali or tamil or
kashmiri
commentaries on the quran or histories
of the prophets
these are written in local languages and
each one of these
becomes a way of transmitting islamic
ideas
into vernacular culture so even though
the quran
is not translated word by word into
vernacular bengali
or hindi or kannada or telugu or any of
the other languages
it is through other media
that islamic ideas are mediated into a
non-arabic speaking people
one mechanism is through the great
sufi shrines that are built in the
punjab now this is in moltan
now in pakistan uh in in the great
province of punjab
the sultans in the 14th century of delhi
would patronize popular
sufi shakes for
simple political reasons these sufi
shakes are
already popular uh their shrines are
great
kind of like magnets attracting hundreds
and thousands of people both hindus and
and muslims so what the sultan does in
order to kind of
curry the favor of local populations is
to build these magnificent
monuments over the gravesites of very
popular shakes
you know it's like american politicians
going to hollywood
and incurring the favor of movie stars
uh you need to to sink your roots in the
local population you identify
who are the people that are locally
understood as charismatic and powerful
we're going to get on their side so as a
political statement
what the sultans of delhi are doing is
by patronizing these great sufi shrines
uh
in in western india they are plugging
into an existing
uh a network of piety uh
namely sufism and so throughout pogba
present-day pakistan we find these
extraordinary monuments i mean
look at the tile again it all echoes
central asian aesthetic
that i already showed you can see that
reflected here very clearly
but look at also what you see here these
are all graves
of people who want to be buried near the
site
where this particular shake uh was was
buried
which is of course the the heart of the
whole monument
so in western india you what you have is
a phenomenon of these great
shrines uh that are kind of like magnets
uh patronized by sultans they're the
ones who paid who write the checkbook
uh they support it they they they pay
the bills
uh and so you have this kind of
connection between local piety
and political power visually very
dramatically seen in these these shrines
these are shrines of the deccan same
idea
the sultans would have patronized these
these monuments
uh in uh again in the punjab you have
these
these these large shrines made of pure
marble again patronized by the sultans
of delhi
uh here is a nighttime celebration at
one of these these shrines and
i'm you've already studied soupism you
understand that you know
these are the every thursday night is
when you have these large
gatherings at uh at the shrines of uh in
the punjab
uh this particular one of pakpatan
here's the grave site of one of these
shrines
uh muslims saying prayers over them uh
here is another uh the tomb of of asha
in in in sin and i just want to draw
your attention the one thing about this
uh which is the the presence of of this
object here which of course you can
easily recognize as a crown
the crown symbolizes the fact that in
sufi
thought the real sovereigns of the world
are sufi sheikhs who
simply kind of designate sultan's
to be their caretakers who do the messy
business of revenue collection
administering justice raising armies
taxation
they do all that but the real sovereigns
of the universe are sufis
who quote unquote appoint the sultans
to rulership and
so there's this fascinating kind of
tense relationship between
political power sultans and sufi shakes
they both claim sovereignty but in
different ways
the sultans are out there fighting their
their battles
collecting taxes and all the rest of it
but they also used sufis many times to
serve as the
in in their coronation ceremonies it's
sufi shakes who actually put the crown
on their head
because it's understood in the sufi
discourse
that sufis are the real sovereigns of
the world and you see that
echoed here in this tomb where we have a
we have
an actual crown and of course many sufis
bear the name
shah which means king in persian this
particular one shah mardan shah he's got
the word twice in there
king shahinsha king of kings
so there is that connection so we go
back to this this this map
which i began with and i want to simply
make one quick
point about again trying to explain why
it is that
the eastern bengal and the western uh
punjab
are the areas where we have the
predominant muslim population
if we look at a distribution of muslims
in bengal as of the first census
1872 we can see it it's the eastern half
which has the highest population up 70
80 percent as high as 90 and above
in in the eastern delta whereas the
western delta
which is where the calcutta is is the
western side
uh it's mainly hindu and
if we look at the distribution of
mosques on the other hand
they're all over the delta but the real
heartland is in the west
along the old gangetic ganges river
somewhat more sparse in the east so you
have this kind of paradox
where the predominant muslim population
is in the east
but the majority of the mosques are in
the west
now my own research was really trying to
understand
how do you resolve that apparent
contradiction
what i found in squirreled away in
record rooms in
in what is now bangladesh eastern bengal
were these 17th and 16th century persian
records
which basically transferred virgin
jungle land forested thick forested land
to developers who were required to
cut the jungle bring the land into
cultivation
rice cultivation wet rice and as a
condition for doing that
they had to build either a temple or a
mosque which then became
the kind of nucleus of of new
communities
in a region where uh the population was
neither hindu nor
muslim already they were practicing kind
of
local bengali religious cults in the
16th and 17th centuries
these mod these documents of which i
found
hundreds of them speak to the gradual
transformation of land
from jungle to rice paddy because they
would actually have pictures
of these bengali mosques and again you
see the curved cornice
now this is not some spectacular
monument that would have
appeared in inscriptions somewhere
they're made of bamboo
and thatching very simple but they
performed a very important role
as being kind of the nucleus of new
communities because there would be a
moazin
and the leader of prayer akhatib who
delivers the sermon
and all this was paid for by the
developer who got the grant
who was given the land uh and as a
condition
for getting rent-free land uh he had to
build these mosques or temples
but if a developer happened to be a
muslim it would be a mosque like this or
like that so that you can see beginning
in the 1720s the distribution of these
they gradually increase
each dot indicates where one of these
mosques were built
and they get thicker as we move into the
1740s and 1750s
what's quite dense this really is the
story of the growth of
of islam in bengal this particular
series of maps are based on contemporary
european maps of bengal
the point of it being that if we look
closely the first
map drawn by a portuguese cartographer
shows if i can do it here we go
the ganges emptying down by present-day
calcutta
sat down as here so the the ganges river
basically flowed in the western part of
the delta
by uh 1615
it splits half of it goes down the west
the other half
goes into the eastern delta by 1760
it's abandoned its old channel down by
satgown which is calcutta here
and the major part of is going into the
central delta
by 1779 the
the ganges has linked up with the great
brahmaputra which goes through east
bengal the point being
that the river system of bengal has
moved from the west to the east
the center the epicenter of civilization
moves with the rivers
uh and calcutta and the western the old
part becomes
progressively abandoned calcutta is
today a dying city
because the old ganges river has
basically abandoned it
whereas the eastern delta gets more and
more fertile because it's getting more
and more fresh water
now this is important because the the
area is politically integrated with the
moguls
at the same time that these rivers are
shifting to the east meaning that east
bengal becomes the area
of uh agricultural as well as political
development a question please
what what is what's the
influence of people's use of the land
around where the river flowed
to influence the rivers
move east okay
is the question why are they moving east
okay that's a geological question and
and the geologists i have two theories
and i'm not gonna get into that i have
no dog in this fight
one theory is uh it's tectonic
that there's there's a there's a fault
line geologically in the east
which is gradually causing the eastern
side of bengal to cave to the
this way for you cave downward uh
you know having to do with continental
uh drift
uh and that that's one theory is when
the other theory is
that all of bengal basically is a flat
pancake
it's it's the whole bangladesh today is
about 30 40 feet above sea level
and and uh
and so all what these rivers are doing
are building
bringing silt down into the bengal delta
the whole area
is basically silt that's been
transformed transferred from
the himalaya mountains topsoil gets
moved down to this area so it's very
rich
because the ganges and the magna and the
brahmaputra
all these rivers are bringing huge loads
of silt down and the
as a consequence the delta keeps getting
pushed further and further south
into the bay of bengal this whole area
therefore is remarkably fertile because
of the because of what the rivers are
doing
so as the rivers move to the east the
east becomes progressively more fertile
and the west becomes less fertile that's
reflected in population figures
population is higher in the east than it
is in the west
and this is also reflected in the
pattern of of development of
of of villages so these records i showed
you these persian manuscripts which
documents which what they're really
showing you is that the land is being
transformed from jungle
to rice paddy and that means that
rice paddy supports a lot more people
than jungle can uh
obviously so all this is happening at
the same time that there's an
agrarian transformation at the same time
that people are being introduced for the
first time to a world religion
that islam is identified with forest
development
and one of the things that's unique
about sufism in eastern bengal
is that sufis are typically identified
with
not just preaching islam but with
preaching agriculture
they're identified with the people who
first brought the
the technology of rice cultivation to
the east
so the muslims of notions of islamic
piety today
are associated with agriculture you talk
to peasants in bangladesh
and they will say that we peasants are
the true muslims
because we're doing what god told
abraham told adam to do that adam was
instructed to take the plow
and to master the earth by plowing the
earth
whereas those folks in the city who are
not plowing the land
are not really as good muslims as we are
so they've internalized this idea
this connection between agriculture and
islamic religion
in ways that are fascinating because
many textbooks you read about islam
repeat this old idea that islam is
somehow of an urban religion
you know it's a middle eastern idea it
might work for baghdad
you know and damascus and the all the
the famous centers of islam in the
middle east
uh but when you move into the indian
subcontinent which is monsoon
there the whole thing is inverted and
that that
islam is now understood as an agrarian
phenomenon and these saints these sufis
are associated with
people who who bring islamic pie to
bengal so i'll close
with this image
the punjab was settled again primarily
by
transplanted uh uh persianized
turks who have been pushed out of
central asia by the mongols
and they bring with them a very central
asian aesthetic sensibility
so that the sultans who are ruling from
delhi
will patronize monuments which could
easily have
appeared in central asia in samarkand in
bohara
any of the great cities of central asia
uh here you have these powerful sufi
sheikhs
who are loaded with barakah or charisma
who
are seen as kind of conduits between us
humans and allah so people want to be
buried there
uh they go there with pilgrimage they
they have hugely important uh
festivals that take place at these these
great shrines uh
in the punjab and so these these become
the magnets uh
for local populations of uh of people
who were not yet hindu
um they're kind of on the way to
becoming hindu but they're not quite
there
yet in the 12th century and
uh and so the punjab has a very
different kind of
uh entree into islam than bengal
in bengal you don't have these great
monuments
what you have are simple thatched
and bamboo huts which become the
earliest mosques
as i've tried to suggest we see that
already in those documents
earlier on and those
are the kind of important
ways in which islam is mediated to a
very different population
in in bengal from punjab one of the
reasons that pakistan broke up in 1971
you know in 1947 you have two wings a
a west and an east
even though bengal is more populated
than than uh
than west pakistan uh east pakistan was
uh was always looked down upon as not
really being muslim
these these bengalis they ate fish and
rice
instead of wheat and meat like us
punjabis
uh and and we we see the aesthetic style
of bengal and punjab also very different
so bengal breaks away from pakistan in
1971 and establishes bangladesh
because islam no longer was understood
as a sufficient glue holding together
these two separate provinces of the
state
and i would argue as you can see here
reflected in architecture
that the whole sensibility of bengali
muslims and punjabi muslims is very
different
uh as as as understood in terms of how
they relate to their shakes
and and their mosques now i know that
we're getting late on time
sam so i i wanted to we we have we can
take a look we have a 20 minute break so
we can cut into it a little bit
so we can take maybe 15 minutes yeah
that's exactly what i want to do is that
this is kind of gives a an overall kind
of um
introduction to the whole story kind of
historical background
and why don't we do that why don't we
take questions and and i'd be happy to
kind of
start this discussion